foreign
[Music]
if you're using Pub sub and want to
learn some best practices for patterns
experimentation and testing then this
video is for you hi I'm Chloe and in
this video I'll be sharing eight useful
features to consider using when working
with Pub sub let's take a look
number one unique naming
when naming your Pub sub resources use
unique names avoid deleting and
recreating the same resources with the
same name to avoid delays from cash
staleness
number two avoid High fan out pattern
High fan out pattern where you would
have a large number of subscriptions is
not recommended as Cloud Pub sub has a
hard limit of 10 000 subscriptions
number three granular subscriber
credentials
if you don't control all subscribers
reading messages from your subscription
make use of granular subscriber
credentials so you can more easily track
who is consuming messages and control
access using IAM policies number four
consistent throughput
Pub sub works best with high throughput
streams of data if you need low delivery
latency but only have a low throughput
stream of data you may want to send
small heartbeat messages to keep a topic
warm number five Pub sub emulator
develop and test your application
locally you can use the pub sub emulator
which provides local emulation of the
production Pub sub service you can run
the pub sub emulator using the Google
Cloud CLI number six add labels
add labels to your Pub sub resources to
break down your Pub sub bill by label
you can break down your Pub sub bill by
label to help you organize your Google
Cloud resources attach a label to each
resource then filter the resources based
on their labels information about labels
is forwarded to the billing system
allowing you to break down your build
charges by label number seven consume
messages by region
when possible consume messages in the
same region or in a nearby region as
where they were published to minimize
Network egress charges number eight
retention duration
if you manage both topic and
subscription and you have topic
retention duration that is longer than
subscription retention duration you can
remove subscription retention to save on
storage costs
there you have it eight useful features
to consider using when working with Pub
sub take a look at our Pub sub
documentation for even more tips and
tricks and check the description below
for links to additional information as
well as step-by-step guides on the tools
discussed in this video we'll see you in
the cloud
[Music]
thank you